[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
accueillant tout de suite nos deux
invités du soir christophe willem et
ryan c'est pire
[Applaudissements]
la conscience
ok
des stripteaseurs alors c'est très
simple ryan malone en doudoune on a une
chemise en dessous un débardeur à chaque
fois on va lancer le dé celui qui fera
le plus petit nombre devra enlever
quelque chose d'assez la première fois
est où les gens se disent vraiment là là
tu fait l'unanimité à mon avis à 100 %
des gens qui veulent que tu gagnes quand
ils veulent que je gagne
[Applaudissements]
ryan c'est toi ta chance et envie de te
dire face et surtout toi et ta mère
[Applaudissements]
c'est cassé c'est cassé c'est cassé
c'est cassé le déboîter c'est pas mal ça
peut passer 1 3 tüv elle a lancé à ce
qu'on appelle la hongroise
[Rires]
[Musique]
hahaha
d'union
au moins
mais là on sait la malgache a pas mal
ont chopé en amortie
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
on fait un dernier coup est ce que moi
je peux et en débardeur ça me dérange
pas ah ben oui j'ai une surprise c'est
mon chiffre aussi procès le
[Applaudissements]
à
ce qu'il ya de bien c'est que lui quand
il arrive en débardeur sur la tête de ma
mère on voit le gars et les gosses bouët
où moi quand j'arrive on me dit pour la
plomberie sans eau
[Rires]
laplaud cas c'est arrivé si interne via
le père leur arriver là alors
sincèrement ces tranches est là la zone
assez cassants
soit la tête de ma version
[Applaudissements]
m
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
ryan
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
et ça descend
[Musique]